neutron stars are one of the most
extreme things in the universe they're
like giant hassle cause kilometers in
diameter unbelievably dense and violent
but how can something like this even
exist the life of a star is dominated by
two forces being in balance its own
gravity and the radiation pressure of
its fusion reaction in the core of stars
hydrogen is fused into helium eventually
the hydrogen in the core is exhausted if
the star is massive enough helium is now
fused into carbon the cause of these
massive stars become layered like onions
as heavier and heavier atomic nuclei
build up at the center carbon is fused
into neon which leads to oxygen which
leads to silicon eventually the fusion
reaction hits iron which cannot fuse
into another element when the fusion
stops the radiation pressure drops
rapidly the star is no longer in balance
and if its core mass exceeds about 1.4
solar masses a catastrophic collapse
takes place the outer part of the core
reaches velocities of up to 70,000
kilometers a second as it collapses
towards the center of the star now only
the fundamental forces inside an atom
are left to fight the gravitational
collapse the quantum mechanical
repulsion of electrons is overcome and
electrons and protons fuse into neutrons
packed as densely as an atomic nucleus
the outer layers of the star are
catapulted into space in a violent
supernova it's
so now we have a neutron star it's mass
is between one and three sons but
compressed to an object about 25
kilometers wide and 500,000 times the
mass of Earth in this tiny ball that's
roughly the diameter of Manhattan it's
so dense that one cubic centimeter of
neutron star contains the same mass as
an iron cube
700 meters across that's roughly 1
billion tons as massive as Mount Everest
in a space the size of a sugar cube
neutron star gravity is pretty
impressive too
if you were to drop an object from one
meter over the surface it would hit the
star in one microsecond and accelerate
up to 7.2 million kilometers per hour
the surface is super flat with
irregularities of 5 millimeters maximum
with a super thin atmosphere of hot
plasma the surface temperature is about
1 million Kelvin compared to 5800 Kelvin
for our Sun let's look inside the
neutron star the crust is extremely hard
and is most likely made of an iron atoms
nuclei lattice with a sea of electrons
flowing through them the closer we get
to the core the more neutrons and fewer
protons we see until there's just an
incredibly dense soup of
indistinguishable neutrons the cause of
neutron stars are very very weird we're
not sure what their properties are but
our closest guess is a superfluid
neutron-degenerate matter or some kind
of ultra dense quark matter called quark
gluon plasma that doesn't make any sense
in the traditional way and can only
exist in such an ultra extreme
environment in many ways a neutron star
is similar to a giant atom core the most
important difference is that atom cores
are held together by strong interaction
and neutron stars by gravity as if all
this wasn't extreme enough let's take a
look at a few other properties neutron
stars spin very very far
young ones several times per second and
if there's a poor star nearby to feed
the neutron star it can rotate up to
several hundred times per second
like the object PSR Jay one seven four
eight two four four six ad it spins
that's approximately 252 million
kilometers per hour this is so fast that
the star has a rather strange shape we
call these objects pulsars because they
emit a strong radio signal and the
magnetic field of a neutron star is
roughly eight trillion times stronger
than the magnetic field of Earth so
strong that atoms get bent when they
enter its influence okay I think we got
the point across neutron stars are some
of the most extreme but also some of the
coolest objects in the universe
hopefully will one day send spaceships
to learn more about them and take some
neat pictures but we shouldn't get too
close
[Music]